there is a major story involving Donald
Trump Supreme Court pick Brett Kavanaugh
Brett Kavanaugh has now been accused of
sexual assault by a woman named
Christine Blasi Ford who wrote to a
Democratic lawmaker saying that back in
high school more than 30 years ago Brett
Kavanaugh sexually assaulted her and
initially the story had gone public
without her name merely that a woman
says this and of course immediately the
smear attempts against this then unnamed
woman started defense's apoplectic
defenses of Brett Kavanaugh and Brett
Kavanaugh simply denied it and this has
sort of forced or at least caused
Christine Blasi Ford to go public with
the story saying it's her story she says
that Kavanaugh and a friend were both
very drunk got her into a bedroom during
a party that Cavanaugh pinned her to a
bed groped her tried to forcibly remove
her bathing suit covered her mouth with
his hand when she tried to scream and
that she eventually was able to escape
when some third guy jumped on all of
them or I'm sorry when the third guy
when Cavanaugh's friend jumped on them
and kind of created a tumble and it gave
her the opportunity to run out of the
room she says that she discussed the six
years ago in couples therapy with her
husband the therapists contained
contemporaneous notes from that time
were released they were reviewed by The
Washington Post and they do match her
story they don't blame Kavanaugh by name
who of course six years ago wasn't about
to become Supreme Court Justice of the
United States so a few different
questions here first and foremost do I
believe her I do I I don't have a reason
to doubt her at this point in time in
addition to everything I told you Brett
Kavanaugh is high school friend mark
judge who is now a conservative writer
said to the Weekly Standard that this
particular incident never happened but
when you look at the book that mark
judge wrote back in 2005 he
writes about the Catholic all-boys
school that they went to he talks about
the drinking and the debauchery and he
mentions in the book about his friend
Bart Cavanaugh which I think we can all
understand is Brett Kavanaugh and he
includes Cavanaugh in sort of the
umbrella descriptions of the drunken
debauchery that took place so at least
that element is in line with what his
own friend has written so then we get to
do I believe the accuser and and my
answer is yes I mean every element of
the story is consistent there are no
obvious contradictions and more
importantly she's getting crushed
smeared and defamed by the right for her
choice to go public about this she chose
to go forward with the story
realistically knowing that this would
happen because even before there was a
name associated with the story the
unnamed accuser was getting smeared and
slammed by the right and that's not
something that people would normally
choose to do over a story that's fake so
that's question one do I believe here I
have no reason to doubt her but the more
important question here is is this going
to matter is this going to impact the
confirmation of Brett Kavanaugh at all I
don't think that it will Donald Trump
was running for president he was on a
recording saying grab him by the [ __ ]
he's accused of serial sexual assault
including the rape of an underage girl
with Jeffrey Epstein I think the guy's
name is and he was still elected
president this is not even some one
subject in Brett Kavanaugh I'm talking
about now to an election it's I mean
it's an election of sorts it's a
confirmation hearing senators need to
confirm him and if you think back to the
Anita Anita Hill situation with Supreme
Court jut now justice then nominee
Clarence Thomas it didn't stop Clarence
Thomas's confirmation when Anita Hill
said she was sexually harassed by
Clarence Thomas and I don't think it's
likely that it will stop Brett
Cavanaugh's confirmation that being said
it might delay the confirmation maybe
long enough for something else to stop
it thinking extraordinaire
optimistically and what I mean by that
is that the vote is scheduled to take
place this week I believe Thursday
September 20th Lisa Murkowski is now the
third Republican who is saying you know
I think we should delay the vote on the
basis of these sexual assault
accusations until we can research
further we will see I don't believe that
this will be the downfall of Brett
Kavanaugh I hope that I'm wrong because
this would be one of the most disastrous
Supreme Court picks in a long time and
we've had some bad ones dating back to
the George W Bush era briefly zooming
out a little bit when you take a step
back from this what you have is one
accused sexual assault er who nominated
another accused sexual assault er to be
on a court that will likely make major
decisions about whether women are or
aren't able to get abortions which is
not a good situation when you take a
look at the big picture and then here's
the last thing and this is just weird
and this is what I want to hear from you
about right after this allegation of
sexual assault against Brett Cavanaugh
went public 65 women 65 testified to the
Senate Judiciary that they knew Brett
Kavanaugh back in high school and he was
just the best little schoolboy very well
behaved great guy Cavanaugh went to an
all-boys school does anybody else find
it a little weird that 65 girls knew him
well enough to be able to testify to his
character when he went to this all-boys
school it sounds a little bit odd to me
that's my question to you not do you
believe the accuser do you find these 65
messages or letters or testimony of
support from women odd and then most
importantly do you believe this is going
to have any impact whatsoever on the
confirmation of Brett Kavanaugh because
that's what matters at this point the
statute of limitations if crimes were
committed in the course of the
allegations described by the accuser
those the statute of limitations has
come and gone the question is will this
impact the confirmation I hope it will I
don't
leave that it will I'm really thrilled
to tell you that today's program is made
possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman as many of you know I have
been working very hard on this program
to reduce stigma around mental health to
reduce stigma around seeking help and I
have a family that is very involved in
mental health and if you've not already
heard about better help it is a
tremendous resource better help gives
you through your phone and computer
affordable private access to licensed
trained accredited experienced
psychologists counselors therapists and
clinical social workers who were
dedicated to helping you through
whatever is going on in your life you
just go to better help calm slash Pakman
fill out a questionnaire they will match
you with a counselor that will work best
for you
they are LGBT friendly you can even say
I want a counselor who's not religious
if that's important to you if your
initial match isn't a good vibe you can
switch to a different counselor and the
beauty is that not only do you get
unlimited counseling over videophone and
text from at home and on the go it is
way cheaper than in-person counseling
and after three months it becomes even
cheaper for you they also have financial
aid for people who need help paying but
you get the same professional licensed
therapy that you would by going to
someone's office and I believe that so
many people would benefit from therapy
whether you're dealing with an acute
situation in your life whether there are
bigger picture difficulties that you're
experiencing please consider checking
out better help calm slash Pakman it's
easy to sign up and get started we've
put a link in the description if you're
watching on YouTube once again that is
better help calm slash PA que ma N